if we get pregnant we have the right not  to be mothers right yeah should men then  in the name of equality have the right  not to be fathers their wallet their  choice they can sign off on child  support why no because if you had sex  with a woman you fully know well that  one of the consequences is that you will  fully like pregnant her and you have a  child so you have to look after child as  that's your responsibility you'll sperm  your responsibility okay you can't run  away from that okay i don't understand  why people in their mind think it's all  right to run away from the child that's  a child you're leaving them with so much  trauma having no like dad and everything  that will leave them with severe like  ideas of how they think about men  because